today I spoke with John Cox who hopes to
first make it on the ballot in November
and then upset the favorite Democrat
lieutenant governor Gavin Newsom I began
by asking about the key issues in this
race there's two key issues there's the
sanctuary state law which the
politicians in Sacramento have passed
and the public is up in arms about
because it protects criminal illegal
aliens instead of trying to protect
law-abiding citizens and the population
the other big issue is the gas tax and
the crushing tax burden in California
instead of actually doing something
about the waste and corruption and Cal
Trans which spends four times what Texas
does to build roads the politicians
passed a huge new gas tax gasoline in
the state's already over $4 a gallon and
it's going to $5 a gallon by the end of
the year it's it's a regressive tax and
it's crushing working people in this
state the top two Democrats and really
you're fighting for one of the top two
spots on the issue of immigration at a
debate earlier this month said this I
think we need to acknowledge that the
dreamers didn't come here on their own
and we've got a say that they've got a
right to have a legalized status one
thing I'm going to do is push back
against John Cox Travis Allen and donald
trump and trumpism this is the kind of
[Applause]
you can hear the cheers there what do
you say to people who question whether
if you get to one of the top two spots
then you can actually pull off a
Republican win in California well you
know I'm a jack kemp Republican I've
served on his presidential steering
committee in 1987 and Jack always
celebrated legal immigration and I think
what we're talking about here is illegal
immigration but more importantly the
sanctuary state law is about criminals
who are held by law enforcement and
ms-13 gang members for example and then
they're being released into the
population without informing ice
I think the public is outraged about
that if somebody who's committed a crime
is in the hands of law enforcement I
want ice informed I want that person
deported the the Democrats are trying to
make this about racism they're trying to
make this about immigration in general
and I want immigration of this country I
celebrate the idea that this country is
the beacon of hope for the world but I
don't want people cutting in line I want
people coming to this country illegally
I think we need to streamline that
process we need a growing economy you
get that with more people contributing
to the economy so I totally favor what
the president's talking about and then
the chain migration improvement of the
opportunity of people who can come to
this country and help us grow this
nation and make it one of the make it
make it continue to be the the greatest
country in the world last thing for
people around the nation the lieutenant
governor there at the end you heard him
say you know I'm gonna fight to John Cox
and Donald Trump and the cheers in
reality because of the politics of this
jungle primary Gavin Newsom is really
kind of supporting you in a way now
isn't he well he'd like to run up
against me but you know Hillary wanted
to run against President Trump too and
we know how that turned out you know
President Trump is a businessman he's
endorsed me because I'm a businessman
and you know Brett you know business
people look for solutions that's that's
what the president's doing he's trying
to solve the immigration problem and
he's delivering results for the American
people
I intend as a businessman to deliver
results for the people of California
make this state affordable make it open
for business fix our roads fix our
schools fix our water system make this
state affordable and sustainable and
livable for the working people of this
state and you know mr. Newsom is a
politician from the word go he's a Bay
Area elitist he's gonna be more of the
same more Jerry Brown big government and
more taxes and a crushing
affordability problem we just can't
continue down that road we're gonna get
a lot of change in 2018
mr. Cox we appreciate your time we'll
follow this race closely thank you
appreciate it Brett